welcome everyone to our first webinar of
2018
and so what happens at you know the end
of every single year is that we make a
lot of changes in December and usually
q4 is such a hectic or that things sort
of get messed up at times and in this
time now it's January to you know look
back and say okay let's fix the madness
let's let's check our ads your landing
pages her offers and get everything sort
of back into shape let's plan for the
new year and of course the ever new year
we need to make her resolutions and then
sort of recap the big things so the one
thing I want to start with is q4 was one
of the most unusual quarters we have
ever seen out of Google in fact it's who
our app we have about a billion dollars
in annual annual spend connected to our
app and so we do a lot of trending data
and I looked at it and I ran the numbers
and I ran them again I said ha this is
really strange is this right and so I
reached out to some very large spenders
some big agencies and said this is what
we're seeing is this what you see - and
they all agreed so in q4 people saw a
one of the largest increases and
cost-per-click
year-over-year ever but that doesn't
tell the whole story all right they saw
an increase in clicked the rates an
increase in conversion rates and for the
first time in any quarter in years
clicks an depressions or flat for most
people they didn't have a big upwards
trying to a downward trend but because
seats here on conversion rates were so
up overall Ross was up and so it was
interesting because it was higher
quality visits from the same or fewer
clicks and so a lot of times who put
together trends to say all right this is
what we expect from a click standpoint a
revenue standpoint a conversion
standpoint so forth
and and while the the revenue numbers
were good in fact they were better than
most people expected Christmas season
this year was a year a week longer than
normal said that that does help but it's
that the click numbers and impressions
were it were flat which affected some of
their trending but not in the revenue
standpoint so what of course we don't
know yet is if that's gonna be a trend
we see in q1 2018 or that was just some
odd anomaly in q4 but you know we make
lots of changes things happen
last-minute especially if you're in
retail and and everything kind of gets
you know out of whack in the accounts so
we need to do is go back and make sure
you don't have issues like this I did
some searches even this morning I am
still seeing ads for Black Friday deals
I still see ads that say we will ship it
before Christmas or shipping cutoff is
December 22nd these are still running
right now right this is this is a
problem because those ads are waste and
impressions and so what you want to do
number one is go through the account and
make sure that if you have had to say
Christmas discounts deals you no longer
offer do some searches select them all
and hit the pause button now where this
is usually overlooked it's easy to go
into Adwords and search for Christmas
select all pause that's pretty simple
he's the image ads a lot of people make
holiday themed image ads and of course
you search doesn't work across you know
OCR optical character recognition within
Adwords so you're gonna want to double
check your images the other thing just
to double-check too is any other
templates you're using I got an email
last Monday from a company into saying
hey welcome to the new year and all this
good stuff that you know comes like to
put out and it still had their Christmas
Bar and logo and everything across it
and of course they're now out of date so
you know number one is let's make sure
anything it shouldn't be running is not
running so the biggest problem you get
when you run and you you know search for
Black Friday and Christmas and specials
you no longer offer and and pause
everything is you end up with ad groups
that have no ads in them and you want
them to be active so an easy easy way to
find out if you have ad groups with zero
active ads in them is go to the old
interface look at the a groups detail
under the dimensions tab and just sort
by active ads you cannot do this and
then new you are yet so some of these a
group details and dimensional reports
are not in the new UI so if you've been
adopting the new way that Google's going
to sort of put together information in a
visual manner of the new interface to
run some of these reports you have to
jump back to the old interface to run
them so then if you have places without
active ads go to the ad groups on pause
ads create as necessary now the other
thing to check negative keywords so you
know we've got one client in the jewelry
industry really high-end jewelry and
during the most of the year they do not
want to show for things like cheap
jewelry costume jewelry discount jewelry
their high-end it doesn't fit their
brand in holiday season
they don't care right they're willing to
put their their rings and necklaces and
stuff at 50% off with everyone else and
in sale during holiday at slightly lower
prices as soon as the holiday is over
they no longer want to show for those
keywords again so either they do things
like keep and negative keyword list
which is actually called saving for post
holiday you know and then they have a
cheap one they remove those from
campaigns during q4 they try to
remember to riad those lists right at
the beginning of the year so if you have
words negatives that you don't use all
year round
I mean you remove for part of the year
it's time to add them again now the next
thing is do you have keywords that need
to be changed or paused so again if you
do searches right now for Christmas
gifts for teenagers you will see ads
with holiday specials in them now other
ones gifts under $20 right men's gift
under $10 those are still valuable
keywords and ones like those used to
make sure that the ads and the landing
pages aren't holiday themes because what
has a tendency to happen this time of
year is some of those ads are still
running and they can be right mints
gifts under $10 that's fine to run all
year round as long as it's go to a page
that says promotion has expired
this will cause a huge increase in
bounce rates naturally so another thing
to to look at real quick is going to
analytics and do a sort of quick time
frame comparison of bounce rates by page
you know middle December versus your
second week of January and sort by the
difference because if you see some while
these pages are bounce rates of
skyrocketed might be some expired
promotions that you're still running
things too so that's another one's you
to definitely check now there's a lot of
other things you should be doing like a
lot of companies are just bid rules so
did you adjust bid rules or did you turn
off automated bidding because you wanted
to do some manual bidding on your top
words you know especially those last few
days of December
did you change extensions it's
overlooked one commonly if you had
extensions that were you know we can
ship by December 22nd and free shipping
may be offered in December but not offer
the rest of the year did you add
discount type words that you don't want
to use anymore
where any final URLs changed you have
audiences interview pause so it's a a
common tactic right from audiences is to
export your CRM list of people who
bought for you last holiday and didn't
buy the rest of the year from you so
common to have a set of holiday buyers
only right and then you make a
customized list of holiday only buyers
and then you uses you to bid boosts or
retargeting just for that group etc so
now they're done shopping all right
through their seasonal buyers for not
everyday buyers so if you have some oohs
audiences made just for that time frame
time to pause those and then of course
hopefully you have a holiday planner
most people start planning for for q4 in
September you know some started in early
as July so take a look at those holiday
plans say okay this is what we are gonna
adjust is what we actually adjusted what
else do we need to change it so that's
really just trying to put all the mass
changes what's weren't tracks very well
for most people you know in q4 back to
where they should be but now it's time
to say okay what are we going to do this
year what's new what can we take
advantage of so when we look at the
major changes in 2017
all right exact and phrase have changed
how they matched it to words we're at
exact match especially now that it is a
semantic match type they're not a
syntactic match type um you're gonna
want to look back and do analysis on
your exact match words and say oh wow
these aren't working very well they
actually should be phrase instead of
exact or here's new negatives um google
launches new ad extensions usually every
few months if you haven't tried the
promotion one yet it's a great one um in
in certain industries the price one is
very good Eatz yeas are are the default
ad now that's that's not new and next
webinar will really dig into ECA data
expanded text that data but the loss
that happened when you had when you went
from year-olds hex adds to the eat CAS
was you couldn't make no preferred ads
anymore you couldn't say this message is
desktop this message is mobile with the
if default ads launched in 2017
you can adjust an ad within just one
format based on someone's device life
event targeting launched you know this
is one that that's very interesting it's
been a common social one for quite a
while you're targeting someone moving
having a kid getting married not enough
people are creative with life event
targeting you know one thing we're
working right now it is a campaign for a
a travel planning site right and so
we're looking at people getting married
with travel planning to do custom
honeymoon destinations as a new thing
for them because they have this new
targeting type Custer magic use
additional fields this is a huge one if
you're especially if you were in b2b and
you uploaded your CRM to a customer
match you know if you got 25% match
rates you're in great shape and b2c it's
common to see 80% plus but Google
launched it because before he's just
email addresses now you can do it name
phone number
zip code so if you've had poor match
rates for custom ads last year look at
your exports and make that data more
complete so you've got higher matches
similar audience is a market launch for
search on great ways for forbid
modifiers Gmail you can add your
retargeting there's now expanded DSA's
if you have an actual store there's much
more in store measurement and of course
a DDA data-driven attribution launched
now that's a lot most people are not
going to do all of these things at once
right so what you want to start thinking
about right is okay let's pick out a few
things
that we want to try because what happens
in in most agencies and in-house
companies is the doing their work and if
things are good enough they they don't
put aside time to try something new or
they wait for something some fire to
happen the the client comes and says all
right so last year everything went up 8%
searches rose 9% so you actually got
worse what what are you doing for me now
right and so being proactive thinking
okay this is what we're going to try out
what we're gonna do
you know in-market audiences for search
or similar those are really good ones if
you're doing DSA is try expanded if
you're not doing any DSA's try them out
do you say so I've come a long ways just
doing the last click bidding say okay
this is the year we need to move away
from last click and really examine
attribution modeling and how he bid
based on attribution now if reporting is
a problem for you which should is in a
lot of places data studio is amazing
Google launched data studio a while ago
but it was very expensive now it's free
and open and you can make a data store
your report that brings in facebook data
Google Analytics data AdWords data Bing
data etc into one place then you can
easily refresh your reports by a
timeframe pull down a PDF send it off to
a client so if reporting's been an issue
try data studio it is really really
powerful and what it can do and gives
you a lot more insights than you pull
out of say AdWords just look at your
statistics now unfortunately when we
survey companies only about 8% have a
marketing plan which is just a terrible
number hey either make a marketing plan
of what you're doing if you have one
review it and update it so that way
everyone's on the same page with this is
what we've done
this is how
set up this is what's next right so
having a sort of concrete plan together
makes it so everyone's on the same page
with what you're doing now
it's 2018 and so what's going to happen
is your goals are gonna change right a
lot of people sit down at the beginning
of the year or usually their financial
years which some cases are are June to
July and they say okay this is what we
want to accomplish and then that's done
at the sea level you know sometimes that
that the VP level and it's put together
with big strategies but it's often not
fully pushed down to direct your levels
and manage your levels who are executing
on this and and was the agency who
doesn't realize their clients goals have
changed so it's always useful to sort of
sit back and say alright what are our
goals for this year is it you know we've
changed how we want to do awareness we
actually want to build awareness and
YouTube campaigns to increase branded
search so we can capture you know and
increase brand awareness for the company
is it that we are looking at increasing
you know total leads while you know
changing how we do some early capture
flow there there's a lot of front ways
that goals change it could be hey we've
added a 24/7 support line we need to do
call tracking now and we need to make
sure for our call tracking we're looking
at leads versus customer support
tracking the leads and push those back
into our analytics so we can make you
know adjustments based upon that what
are the goals my favorite question to
ask the client is what will make you
happy if we hit X goal you're a happy
client because that way they've said
something concrete
here's a number right we want a three
hundred and seventy-five percent row
loss with at least a million in revenue
per month
that's a concrete number right now you
can look at what you're doing and say
this is what makes them happy if we do
this we're in good shape right so having
an a client could be your boss right if
you're in house the Contra boss it's
it's other you know companies within
your larger organization it's
understanding what is a go you're
working for also helps you look at all
these new features so okay that's gonna
help me accomplish is not what's not
gonna do anything for us
do you have new products and services
all right this is another time to look
back and say has our website changed has
our base core offers changed right so if
you have new products you need to do
some keyword research forward do you
have new services time to do that that
keyword research right this is a very
important consideration because often in
you know December people add a lot of
products which aren't sold in January
that's pausing them a lot of times in an
early year the thing what's new now but
the next thing with with products
especially in service based companies is
to say to have our timelines per product
changed so what we'll see with um most
companies so I live in in Northeast
United States which means we got a lot
of snow usually in the winter time this
year it's been much warmer so the
companies who usually do basement
refinishing right they are the base
bands they they make them nice and
liveable and so forth they're also the
same people who build decks for outside
your house or your porches this year's
been much warmer than normal so what
we're seeing is usually people who own a
house they do their porches in that they
do their their basements in the
wintertime they do their porches in the
summertime it's been so warm at times
that these companies who normally don't
advertise for porch you know portrait
finishing building porches so forth
are actually booking business if they're
marketing and the fact that they're
doing at this time of year right so when
you think about products and services
it's also has the timeline changed based
upon other seasonal effects um of when
you want to do it you're about to head
into tax season so if you are a tax
based company right are you ready for
how all the different taxes are going to
play out across the countries I mean so
that that's important overall to look at
now the other new thing coming down
which is also important look at if you
do business in in Europe are the the
changes to some of the privacy policies
that's happening you know some companies
have to readjust their marketing because
they have to readjust their data
collection so if you're working with
another company and you're using
something as simple as customer match
right and they're doing and automated
you know export you're doing an
automated FTP of the data and it's just
been kind of sending the background
running for the past year or two that
export may suddenly change in the next
few months and so if the companies
you're dealing with have to make changes
for legal regulations and that affects
the marketing right that's not so a new
product or service but it is a change to
how their current products services are
marketing for it for the current ones
will also adjust and and some of the the
stuff coming down in Europe is going to
have some large large impacts on
companies but it's it's really look at
have goals changed what makes the client
happy what's new in the company then
look at here's all the new features
which one of these is going to make us
the most revenue and you move the needle
the most now let's go put a plan in
place right to accomplish those and if
you don't have a plan to accomplish it
it's gonna get pushed off and pushed off
and pushed off it never actually
happened something those my
Soames is very important you know what
do you want to accomplish if this is not
set out in in January it often never
gets done it's sort of like a task list
versus a project plan right a task list
it's just a lot of things to do someday
when you get to it and it's easy to keep
adding tasks and never finish them or
just push them off a project plan says
this is the date it will happen this is
the the tasks that need to be done to
hit that particular milestone so as
you're looking at all these potential
changes right you need to look at your
schedule look at the assets you have on
what's needed and make a clear project
plan to accomplish those things you know
when we think about New Year's
resolutions right so the ones that most
companies should either do or already
have completed one is track every single
conversion it is sort of amazing that
you know it's not 2018 and the sheer
number of companies who do not track
most conversions it is quite high um
with chatbots on the rise right now very
few people who actually can do
conversions within a chatbot are
tracking them of course call tracking
real simple one right CRM systems
another big feature launched last year
is there's a Salesforce and Google 360
integration so at a lot of companies
right now you know their leads go to
Salesforce and then they they track the
lead and they optimize off the lead
and then within Salesforce they sort the
lead they score the lead and eventually
that the lead hopefully closes right not
all - now there's a big gap between a
lead a qualified lead and a closed so if
you're using say
Salesforce you can now sync back closed
leads back to back to GA and in to
AdWords so that you're working off
closed leads not leads because everyone
who's just tracking leads has always had
that the conversation when the client
that says they're not qualified right
and there's no way to know why they're
not qualified in some cases and so
that'll help close the loop of this is
not as a qualified lead but as sale and
with the new integrations between
systems especially Google 360 and
Salesforce
um you can work off of actual sales
audience targeting right this is one
that remarketing which is substantive
audience targeting very very fast
adoption for most companies I mean if
you're in retail you've already done
probably dynamic remarketing yeah it's a
pretty simple thing to execute fantastic
returns but what we don't see is really
good audience targeting when it comes to
segmenting the website first and only
targeting a subset of users or using
your CRM data to take advantage of
audience targeting there's still huge
amounts of gains to be had with audience
targeting if you're creative about it I
mean a creative uses we had last years
one of the company who sells classes
right now classes are an object right
they're not they don't have a gender to
them they don't have an aids to them
they're just a piece of metal with some
you know glass in the middle right they
used to see better so this coming to
struggle a little bit and it's and and
whenever someone's struggling it's
always how do we connect better with the
users right how do we get more granular
question number one so we had them take
these glasses and we put them on one
model who is an older female one model
is a younger female another model who is
an older male another model who's a
younger male right so now we've given
context to these glasses we can now go
into Adwords we can make a campaign that
says show this image
two young females show this image to
older females and men's and so forth
completely changed right their ability
to sell these because now people could
look and say oh it's not just an object
I can see that
on myself because I'm seeing a
reflection right of my persona in the ad
copy move to extended text as we're
gonna do our our next webinar on ETS um
when we look so our system has something
like 380 million search ads in it
roughly half of all accounts more than
twelve roughly half of all ads more than
twelve months old are still standard
text ads all right et A's have better
conversion rates they stand out a lot
more than stas so it is time to finish
any move and most companies have started
to move to ETA s there if you have
finished it now if your accounts less
than a year old
you only have ETA so that's not as big
of a deal except in the creating them
properly which will still address in our
our next webinar GD n you know I all
text ads for sunset it from from GD n a
year ago and responsive ads are still
highly underused so if you're gonna do
audience targeting right across the
Google Display Network you should try
out the responsive ad formats because
they can show and some inventory slots
no images can such as native I mean
they're really good assets to see how
they do in various sizes is the site
really mobile-friendly alright and and
hopefully your answer is yes most people
it's just these days still see a lot of
non mobile-friendly sites if it it
doesn't matter if you're b2c b2b um what
you sell site should be mobile-friendly
these days and there's still a lot that
aren't you know google just announced
officially that speed is gonna be part
of the mobile
ranking algorithm for for organic it's
already been won on the desktop but it's
gonna be a noble one too
so you know with progressive web apps
and an amp it's gonna be a more
important consideration going going
further if you haven't tried an Amex or
said yet right try DSA's you tell Google
hey this large you know long held my
website we're not picking the ads for
every page and cure every page let them
do it right use machine learning to your
benefit test more no one can ever go
wrong by trying to test more right make
sure your ad extensions are complete
there are a lot of ad extensions a
underused ad extensions when you don't
you have have a complete set um it
affects your metrics significantly right
every campaign should have four to six
site links four to six um call-outs for
four restructured snippets and so what
you usually see is most campaigns have
some of this but not a full completeness
so when you do your audit audit your AG
extension usage and make sure it's
complete across the account try multi a
group testing you know most most
companies do I'm single a group testing
which means they're testing two ads
within an ad group and that'll give you
the best ad for targeting method but
what it doesn't do is tell you this is
the best ad for a campaign or account
um because that gives you more insights
to customer behavior what's gonna be
useful then in email marketing or
webpage design and it finally manage PPC
like a project and not a to-do list
that makes everybody more efficient and
of course we're here at simply learn we
believe did resolution number one of all
time should be get an education right
Google changes fast things change
quickly but there are principles that
are timeless right good ad copy writing
is timeless working in the current
format right that may be based on the
latest format
but the overall idea of ad copy it's a
timeless idea it's to make sure you have
a good education to back up all these
features that exist and and you know to
make sure that you are getting good
education we're gonna do our next
webinar on ETS and so if you have
already converted we're gonna look
through things like how the length of
ETA s affects metrics we'll look at you
know how ETA s do compared to Stas
what's really necessary we'll get an
attribution management so hopefully
you're doing attribution now if you're
not bidding by it and taking full
advantage of all the types of ways do it
we will get into that in march and
demographics of ad creation right so how
do you put glasses on a model who echoes
your demographics productivity is one of
my all-time favorite topics and then
large scale I testing how brain says
this so that's what's coming up and so
when you think about your news New
Year's resolutions right let's fix what
we have let's make our resolutions our
goal is to really say here are the
things you need to do to hit your
resolutions and make sure that
throughout the year you're getting more
and more efficient from your account all
right and with that I'm gonna say thank
you and ask Richard if we have any
questions and so forth
to go through how excellent and I always
have questions Brad is the way I am but
before we dive into the question and
answer session of this webinar I want to
bring up a few things first I would like
to thank Thank You Brad for your time
here today and for an enjoyable session
maximum thank you you're welcome
yeah I always these are always wonderful
I learned so much from these on session
recordings if you're interested in
getting a session recordings we do
record them and you can go over to the
simply learn website and be a chat or
email just request for a copy of the
webinar
let them know that your you had Brad and
the date and they'll send you a link to
it and that way you'll have a copy if
you want to go back because we do he
cover a lot of information I had trouble
tracking it all and I'm taking notes so
so start the question off with the one
question I see just about every webinar
I'm in and you know please if you have a
specific question to your career path or
for your company or business you know
bring it up in the chat or the Q&A I
know we already have some people who are
sending some stuff in chat so I'm
looking at both of those but the first
question going to bring up is it we a
lot of people who are on a career path
who want to dive into marketing and
where do you start
I mean if you've never done any
marketing and that's kind of like a fun
niche to be and is figuring out what
AdWords to put out there and what tools
are available where do you even begin
getting an education on that or getting
the basic started on that Brad well I
mean our courses simply learn right I
mean that's that's that's a softball
question from in reality though right
when when you think of a marker these
days a marketer needs to be able to do
three things well right they need to
first know how to drive traffic so I
mean I teach I words of course it could
be organic it could be social you have
to drive traffic right to a site or an
asset it could be an app whatever right
that's step one step two then is
understanding how that traffic's doing
which is analytics right how is how is
my traffic actually performing and then
question no once you can answer that
right question three is how do I make it
better which is conversion optimization
right so a complete marketer usually
unless you're a statistics guru and you
want to start an analytics or something
right which is completely viable almost
people need to drive traffic analyze
traffic make the traffic convert better
and then usually go circle back and say
what other ways can I Drive traffic
right and then and then move from you
know in Adwords to an organic organic to
a social and so it's kind of like this
big complete loop of that if you can
only do one of these great you won't be
a team you may be a team leader but
you'll never be a director right a
director level has to know how to work
with all three departments right so
that's why usually it's easiest to get a
job starting in analytics or traffic
driving then once you've taken that
first step you know then you move via
three steps once you understand the
entire process right then you can move
up from the company to be a director
level VP etc but very few people can be
directors without being able to talk to
all the departments how's that for a
long-winded answer yeah I was excellent
they actually didn't - my next question
which I certainly worked with many
startup companies to larger companies
and and I don't work in the side of
marketing I work more in the data
analytics side but one of the things I
always run into is and you're you were
talking earlier what was it was data
studio being able to build reports and
in your personal experience how do you
convince the head of the company they
need to spend the money I mean that's
always a big one you know we need to
spend this amount of money and this
amount of time on this and look at you
go no we don't want spend any money and
then you have to come back to them and
explain why how do how do you address
that it's so personality driven right
it's so personality driven there's a lot
of ways right number one is is you put
together a chart that says this is you
this is your competition they're beating
you because of XY and Z right and
usually showing a c-level why they lose
it is a good place to pull some money
from a another one is to to move to more
historical situations so it was
interesting right in
and the big economy down to her like
five years ago a lot of companies just
stopped spending right they just they're
like the economy's down where self
spending and and post the change if you
look at their stock prices they were
very slow to move now another subset of
companies kept spending through it right
they they might have lowered budgets
they never stopped
and once he comma turned around their
stock price uptick because they
understood the market still was much
deeper and they're actually still much
ahead of the communist who didn't right
and so sometimes if you've got a CEOs
been you know they're for twenty years
or something and seen a lot of changes
you know using that historical one can
be very useful in showing this sort of
happens you'd understand your market and
of course number three is bring a and
I'm not saying this in disparaging
lights but it's it's it's one that some
come and bring a millennial to the
meeting and say okay I want you to look
how this person interacts with the world
and tell me you understand it because
odds are when they pull up in snapchat
to start the day and they take a picture
of the CEO and put an Instagram say this
is who I'm meeting with right now and
this and that the long CEOs look at him
go like I have no clue what you're doing
they're out of touch with the market
they already can see that right for
themselves in person it was okay we need
to spend money to actually understand
the market changes that are happening
and they gave you a quite a chuckle
breakable lineal had a curiosity of the
attendees how many of you are
Millennials if you know what I answered
that's okay we're not gonna put anybody
on the spot that might even leave a very
interesting job description I'm your
token millennial to bring to a meeting
because like I I I had a meeting with on
a CEO of fortune you know 50 are
probably 50 maybe 75 company and my
niece was in town and you know my
niece's she's now 17 she was 14 at the
time and I was I live in DC right so so
nerd on DC and
like you know what kind of meeting with
me and so you know I introduced him to
my niece in the meeting and and actually
walked through and said this is how she
sees the world right and and showed like
four or five apps from her phone and
which they couldn't see you know these
are things you can't see because you're
not her close friend and this and that
and it was very eye-opening for the CEO
who was you probably only mid-50s right
like not yeah I mean again is suffering
in two ages but you know probably only
mid-50s but just did not understand the
world and they sold consumer goods right
he's looking at her like you are going
to be who we sell to in about three to
four years of time you'll be you know
one of the top purchasing segments of
the economy because Millennials they're
a much larger population than then the
Gen Xers and and you know to how to want
to breakout Gen X in a way etc on their
large population set and you know
starting now they are the ones who are
becoming the directors of companies in
this night and you gotta understand them
because they they buying power finally
I'm in a lot of buying power I have
three Millennials of my own change the
companies don't get in how they spend
money right so you know previously
people wanted to buy a house right in
and the number of people who want to own
a house is actually decreasing because
the Millennials often want a I stir used
to the Netflix economy right where I pay
11 bucks a month and I see this I you
know I pay my phone this I get this back
right instead of use to a monthly
ongoing fee and so you know that the a
lot of things that used to be just
bought are now rented or in in that's
what we see a big jump in like say
clothing that's actually rentable right
we're like my demographic we just bought
our suit
ray you I you have a few suits you're
good to go right and now it's more
common to see someone you know rent
to suit for a weekend or subscribe to a
site that lets them get a new dress
every every week or every month and it's
a subscription based economy much more
than it used to be which changes how a
lot of CPG companies need to think about
ownerships of products mmm I think yeah
that's we've seen that with Microsoft
Office you know that it instead of
owning it
Adobe same thing you know you you you
you pay subscription fees for Adobe you
don't download software you download
software but it's not the same payment
method because they've adjusted to
Memorial economy oh wow so another
question coming in at a company level
how do you get the team to be on the
same page when you're doing with a large
company that's always a challenge
because you have you know like you said
there's personalities you got three
people going one way and two people
going another way is there a way to get
them like in a same class together or
get them on the same tastes and you're
doing marketing how would you do that
how would you market the marketers yes
so this May 10th webinar for the
productivity and communication is is one
of my absolute favorite topics I'm a bit
of a crazy person on a part city side
and and so it usually starts with
project management software right this
is what everyone is doing this is view
so you can see what's actually being
worked on and so Evans on the same page
that's number one number two right it's
a communication system or communication
culture now you have to be careful with
this right slack great except the
problem with slack is it's constantly
interrupting all right so like we use
slack for corporate communication but
it's it's muted by default so it's like
checking email right okay I need to go
check that the company slack and see
what's done but it's not interruptive
because that'll that'll kill the
productivity is that that you know micro
interruption stuff and and three
is usually how meetings are won and
attended so information trickles down
correctly right most meetings are highly
inefficient they involve too many people
and they don't have strict rules with
them I'm really am a crazy person with
this I have meeting rules and so you
know making sure the correct people are
there and then disseminated to those who
need to know but don't need to attend
right is another important culture
change but to me everything starts with
project management software that makes
the company feel they're efficient not
another task to do which is why not
every every Cummins be different what
they really want to use just drop the
communication and to start the same page
and then a secondary communication
system of what needs to be done versus
what you need to be informed of versus
this stuff you don't need to know and if
we send it out we're just clogging up
your ear your inbox and you're not
getting to the stuff that's important
right being judicious and what actually
gets communicated is important as well
nice yeah that's yes
that's excellent advice communication
they say what is it communication and
business is like location and real
estate communication communication
communication as I was in the real
estate software industry for many years
it's also education with customers right
not just internally otherwise you get in
is like self-fulfilling prophecy area so
it's communication but that's that's you
know people below you people your level
people above you and then your customers
and that's the part that I find is often
skipped in companies mmm
see the companies I've dealt with had
the opposite problem they were so
focused on the customer they forgot to
talk to each other hmm
which was always a challenge it's
becoming more common with virtual based
companies because there's no longer
water-cooler conversations right and and
that's where having some other way of
dealing with stuff like we have one kind
of work with there there are roughly
half virtual and half in an office so in
their office building everyone has
virtual actually has a desk with a
modern
with the webcam on top so everyone can
still see each other working can stop by
the desk and have a conversation and so
that way it's kinda like a virtual
presence that that is taking over as
opposed to you know invisibility behind
nothing right behind a screen or an
email and text which doesn't have
correct context at times hmm Wow that's
kind of weird I don't know if I'd want
to work underneath the webcam I would
find that challenging maybe I get used
to it
yeah it's no different than working in a
cube that everyone can see I could see
that and and other times this is video
meetings right so like at at Google
everyone uses gvc Google video chat so
every office has a big screen on it and
has a webcam in it so every time you sit
in a meeting right you people even in
the same building often sit in different
meeting rooms which is just weird to me
but whatever you sit down you flip on
the webcam and flip on the screen so at
least you're talking to a person and not
like this right open voice to a flat
screen and that personal communication
being able to see someone in body
language helps the conversation a lot
since you 90% of communication is
nonverbal when you only talk verbally
you are you miss large domestic
communications are actually happening
and so video can introduce a huge amount
of additional signals which make
communication much better between people
excellent in let's just go with one more
quick question because we are at the end
of the hour but we'll go just a few
minutes over since we didn't start a
little bit late what are some of your
favorite tools that you see being used
in companies you've mentioned a few like
Salesforce Google 360 slacker one that
I've used before in obviously slacker is
just is more of a chat thing but some of
them require like sales forces is huge
usually requires some training for
Salesforce we have classes in Salesforce
versus you know like a chat box like
slacker you just kind of put it up there
and everybody uses it what are some of
your favorite tools and and which ones
are the ones that
you would need to get everybody trained
on versus something that is is quick and
easy like slacker and where do they fit
in those niches yeah I mean so I so we
use the Trello or Jireh it for our
project management Trello is super easy
to use but it's but it's also limited on
features rate we're Jireh owned by the
same company Atlantean is incredibly
complex to use but has a thousand times
the features so that's often the
trade-off right is it is the less
features it has the less training that's
needed now sometimes you don't need lots
of features right and it's overkill
right sometimes a high rise for a small
company which is a CRM system is just as
good as a Salesforce right if you're 20
people you probably don't need
Salesforce if you're you know 2,000
people you probably need Salesforce so
so sometimes the these simpler programs
are the better ones depending on
corporate size but you know I love Jireh
and Trello from a project management
standpoint um we use slack we Google
Docs so or or 360 I mean either one but
it's the collaboration features and the
live usage so we can pull up you know a
spreadsheet in real time among five
people we can point and time a
conversation about each individual cell
or formula or whatever that we want to
work on and that's change collaboration
quite a bit right so a productivity
suite that is collaborative focused it
is a huge one a video chat system right
whether it's go to meetings Skype Google
Hangouts whatever it is so that way it's
not just pick up the phone but you got
more video interaction with users
another one I actually love which does
take some training is is Camtasia which
is the video creation software so you
know one of the things you run into is
someone asks the same question over and
over again right that's that everyone
has this so will create videos like one
or a software company right so will
create a video for so and says here's
how you do this and we'll send them the
video
of it so if they ask us again we sent
and went back to the video if someone
else asked us how to do it send the link
to the video so it's like this ever
you know evergreen content that is
better than an email explaining how to
do something that's more personal for a
lot of people that doesn't think
anyone's any longer once you learn it so
I can't as your studio is we heavily use
it for customer support
um customer support so some sort of
helpdesk system is obviously important
are our favorite these days is I forgot
the name which one we're using we
switched about three months ago and I
liked it better and I forget what it's
called yeah well um you know but a a
ticketing system - for you know customer
communications are very important a
social interaction tool so that way you
can see what customers are saying or aid
I mean this is like you know a HootSuite
or something for if you're very large
HootSuite requires training something
like a buffer does not but HootSuite
lets your customer support people talk
back to a you know your customers and
social media while aggregating reports
at the same time you can send up the
chain and turn internally this is our
current social media presence so I think
everyone's a little bit different in
what they need but you know those are
probably some of our most common tools
to use excellent excellent
yeah I always it amazes me how many
tools we have out there in if you google
something nowadays you end up like five
billion of them and then you have to
sort through them so sometimes just from
the basics of just finding out what
other people are using gets you in the
right direction and yeah you can see
what comes up on the different trends
that would be we've gone a little bit
past the hour so we'll go ahead and
close the session up again I want to
thank you for being here I was a
wonderful session
Brad appreciate your time and your
expertise today Thanks thank you and
thanks for monitoring and keep the song
on task with all of our all of our
attendees are archived for the day as
well that's right if you do have any
questions
they do come in here you can go over to
simply learn we have the forums
community simply learn comm you can also
come into the main simply learn comm
webpage and there's a chat window that
comes up so you can ask them about the
classes the public forums go a little
bit more in detail as far as I guessing
more specific questions and you can also
just contact simply learn too if you
have additional questions specifically
to this webinar and then they'll forward
that over to Brad if you have something
that comes up look forward to seeing
everybody in our classes if you have any
questions again go to simply learn comm
and thank you for being here it's great
to everybody here and we look forward to
seeing you in our next webinar Thanks
thank you everyone for attending and
thank you rich for hosting us hi there
if you like this video subscribe to the
simply learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos turner up
and get certified click here